[Applaus]
[Musik]
krieg und zerstörung krisen und armut
versuchst du und terror ich bin mir
sicher dass euch genau diese mentalen
bilder durch den kopf gehen wenn von der
folgenden ecke der welt die rede ist
dies als blockade des gazastreifens
verursachte laut uno zwischen 2007 und
2008 10 verluste von 14 milliarden euro
un bericht vom februar 2021
palästinensische sozio ökonomische
entwicklung erleidet eines der
schlechtesten jahre seit 1994 21 zweimal
2021 israel und hamas zu vereinbaren
einen waffenstillstand nach 11 tägigen
kämpfen
der konflikt hat mindestens 230
palästinenser und zwölf israelis das
leben gekostet
das allererste jedoch worüber wir uns im
klaren sein sollten ist worüber wir hier
eigentlich genau sprechen
[Musik]
geografisch gesehen können wir sagen
dass palästina jenes gebiet ist das
derzeit aus jordanien israel und
natürlich der palästinensischen
autonomiebehörde besteht die auch vor
der un und viele regierungen der welt
als palästinensischer staat anerkannt
wird palästinenser sind also geografisch
gesehen alle menschen die in dieser
region leben egal ob juden oder moslems
araber oder israelis es gibt aber auch
diejenigen die der meinung sind dass
palästina nur jenes der tour umfasst in
dem sich das heutige israel
westjordanland und gaza bis hinten und
andere wiederum beschritten ist in der
praxis nur auf das heutige
westjordanland und gaza und zwar
gewaltig interessieren natürlich sowohl
geschichtliche hintergründe als auch
politische fakten das heißt politik mit
realen auswirkungen da wir uns heute
jedoch ganz speziell mit den teils
anerkannten heutigen staates palästina
beschäftigen beziehen wir uns in diesem
video immer auf ihnen wenn wir von
palästina und palästinensern sprechen so
da die begrifflichkeiten ungeklärt sind
lasst uns doch die wirklichen fragen
angeht die da werde wer trägt im
palästinensischen staat die
verantwortung wie ist er organisiert und
wie effektiv ist dieser staat eigentlich
bei der beantwortung dieser fragen wenn
ihr heute versuchen nicht zu viel über
geschichte zu reden zumindest nicht so
viel wie sonst und auch nicht über
kriege wir werden sogar versuchen nicht
über israel zu sprechen außer wenn ich
es unbedingt notwendig ist und bestimmte
zusammenhänge zu verstehen denn diesmal
wollen wir jenes palästina kennen lernen
dass wir nichts aus den reißerischen
schlagzeilen und oft einseitigen
hiobsbotschaften der mainstream medien
kennen klingt gut nicht wahr
na dann lasst uns jetzt schnell loslegen
zwei konflikte zum preis von einem
palästina ist ein territoriales
politisches und soziales gebilde in den
otto 5 millionen menschen leben so war
die theorie in der praxis ist können wir
nichts von einem einzigen palästina
sprechen sondern müssen über zwei
palästinas reden die palästinenser in
der westbank und die des gazastreifens
und du kannst mit glauben wenn ich dir
sage dass diese zumindest politisch
überhaupt nicht auf einer wellenlänge
liegen
in der tat ist die dauerfehde der
palästinenser gegen israel nicht der
einzige heiße konflikt denn den sie
vermittelt sind und genau aus diesem
grund stoßen immer wieder auf
nachrichten wie diese dreizehnter juni
2007 in gaza bürgerkriegs zwischen
palästinensischen fraktionen aus wir
sprechen hier über an kunst liegt der
sehr weiter zurück reicht bereits die
historisch bedeutsamen palästinensischen
führer ahmed jassin mitbegründer und
politische und religiöse führer der
hamas bewegung und legendäre jassir
arafat gründer der politischen partei
und führer der palästinensischen
befreiungsorganisation kam überhaupt
nicht miteinander aus so sehr dass man
am ende des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
schlagzeilen wie diese lesen konnte
hamas-führer unter hausarrest gestellt
der beispiellose schritt gegen scheich
ahmed jassin kamen nach dem
palästinenserführer jassir arafat
versprochen hatte als reaktion auf den
angriff der das neue friedensabkommen im
nahen osten zu untergraben drohte hart
gegen militante fotogen der angriffe auf
den sich diese meldung bezieht richtete
sich nicht gegen palästina sondern gegen
israel
aber manchmal ein palästinenserführer
ließ einen anderen preis unser führer
verhaften weil letzterer israel
angegriffen hat
ja das ist korrekt und tatsache ist dass
die plo die palästinensische
befreiungsorganisation zwar dem
abschluss von friedensabkommen mit
israel zu stimmte die hamas eine
antizionistische und rassistische
organisation diese idee jedoch für
unerträglich hielt und auch bis heute
noch hält für sie ist die anerkennung
des existenzrechts eines jüdischen
staates eine absolute rote linie die sie
nicht zu überschreiten bereit ist und in
der tat ist diese rote linie
ob frieden mit israel geschlossen werden
sondern da nicht jeder dreh und
angelpunkt mit denen die gewaltige
politische spaltung der palästinenser
gerechtfertigt wird natürlich neben den
typischen stellvertreterkrieg der immer
zwischen sich bekriegen fraktionen
stattfindet dass er jedes ist dass diese
halbe stadt derzeit praktisch in zwei
separate territorien mit sich sehr stark
unterscheidenden regierungen mitteilt
ist die zudem indirekt kommt trotzdem
200 stehen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
beide palästinensischen fraktionen
betrachten israel als besatzungsmacht
aber sie sind sich wieder darüber einig
wie sie mit dem hebräischen stadt
umgehen soll noch über die roadmap und
die richtung die ein zukünftiger ohne
eingabe sischer staat an sich
einschlagen sollte
die folge ist eine tiefe soziale und
politische spaltung des landes auf der
einen seite im westjordanland regiert
die fatah partei die der
palästinensischen autonomiebehörde
vorsteht welche hilfe der uno und
einigen ländern als staat anerkannt wird
auf der anderen seite im gazastreifen
herrscht hamas eine terrorgruppe über
die visuelle politik schon oft
gesprochen haben hier wird schon das
sind die jungs die gerne mit raketen auf
israel ballern und ntt heranzüchten
[Musik]
beide fraktionen haben sich im laufe der
zeit weiterentwickelt und präsentieren
heute sehr unterschiedliche auffassungen
sowohl von arabisch israelischen
konflikt als auch des palästinensischen
staats modells an sich
[Musik]
während in gaza streifen das
scharia-recht eine extrem strenge
version des islamischen gesetzes mit
schweren körperlichen strafen und
hinrichtungen im schnellverfahren kommen
soll es mittelalterliche praktiken im
westjordanland der palästinensischen
autonomiebehörde nicht vor oder
zumindest nur minimal darüber hinaus
arbeitet die ph in politischen und
sicherheitspolitischen fragen ganz
offiziell mit der israelischen regierung
zusammen wäre in gaza ein offener und
direkter krieg gegen die juden geführt
wird natürlich ist die heutige teilung
palästinas das ergebnis einer ständigen
abfolge von konflikten spaltungen und
gescheiterten abkommen der und
kleingedrucktes jedem menschen
kopfschmerzen bereiten würde
da wir uns nun also der tiefen spaltung
bewusst sind die diesen halbstadt plagt
lasst uns direkt zur schlüsselfrage
kommen wie genau funktioniert palästina
heute also aufgepasst
[Musik]
ein land das 100 mal geteilt ist
palästina als das hundertfach geteilte
land zu bezeichnen ist nicht nur eine
redewendung sondern passt in diesem fall
ganz gut zur realität eines der größten
probleme des heutigen palästina ist die
absenz territorial zusammen heißt dies
macht den betrieb eines effektiven staat
ist er in der lage ist sein territorium
adäquat zu verwalten und zu
kontrollieren sehr kompliziert schon
einmal diese karte an
neben der teilung palästinas enders
westjordanland den gazastreifen und
wurde auch innerhalb des westjordanlands
das gebiet aufgeteilt wenn auch auf eine
etwas merkwürdige art und weise
warum wurde um das zu beantworten müssen
wir wieder zurück zu den osloer
verträgen von 1993 mit diesem abkommen
wedelten israel und die palästinensische
behörde ihre streitigkeiten und einigten
sich auf die schaffung von gebieten mit
unterschiedlichen grad an
selbstverwaltung und unabhängigkeit in
der westbank drei kategorien wurden
vereinbart b und c in gebieten des typs
a haben die palästinenser sowohl zivile
als auch militärische und
sicherheitsrecht liche kontrolle in den
gebieten des dfb haben sie die zivile
kontrolle aber die militärische
kontrolle teil sich palästinenser und
israel
und schließlich gibt es gebiete des typs
c eigentlich alles territorium in
welchem jedoch israel die zivile und
militärische kontrolle hat das problem
ist nun dass trotz der tatsache dass die
palästinenser in den gebieten a&w den
höchsten grad an selbstbestimmung in
ihrer geschichte haben die kommunen von
der hamas und einem teil der
palästinenser als eine kapitulation
gegenüber israel gesehen wurden als zu
große konzession im verhältnis zu den
bestrebungen der präsidentin ablegen die
straße zu erreichen
tatsache ist dass dieser flickenteppich
bis heute bestand hat
um zb von einem in ein anderes gebiet zu
gelangen muss man ein ziel gebiet
durchqueren das heißt mehrere der
unzähligen militär check points im
gesamten westen oder land passieren das
abkommen sieht jedoch vor dass die
kontrolle über die zielgebiete
schrittweise von israel an die neu
geschaffene palästinensische
autonomiebehörde übergeht bedingungen
hierfür ist jedoch eine gewisse garantie
der sicherheit
es hat dies bisher nur schleppend
vorangeht dann gibt es auch um das thema
der sie lohnt neu errichtete städte und
dörfer die sich im westjordanland
befinden und zu einem der größten
stolpersteine auf dem weg zu einer
endgültigen einigung geworden sind es
geht um etwa 700.000 israelische bürger
von denen etwa 300.000 jerusalem und
400.000 in judäa und samaria leben damit
diese einigermaßen gefahrlos reisen
können werden die verbindungsstraße nach
israel von israelischen
sicherheitskräften kontrolliert auch
manchen davon dürfen palästinensische
fahrzeuge jedoch nicht verkehren was zu
einer weiteren auf trennung des
palästinensischen gebiets führt
[Musik]
kurz gesagt wir haben es mit einem
klassischen preis zu tun lockerte israel
die vorkehrungen welche offensichtlich
eine menge frustration oder der
chinesischen bevölkerung erzeugen sind
die sicherheit ist kommt dann immer
wieder zu brutalen anschlägen radikaler
terroristen aus palästina gegen israelis
und die spirale der gewalt dreht sich
immer schneller
und das ist noch nicht alles wie wir
bereits gesagt haben sind die
palästinenser selbst gespalten denn gaza
und das westjordanland funktioniert
vollkommen getrennt voneinander
tatsächlich ist es für ein palästinenser
aus dem westjordanland viel einfacher
sich in israel zu bewegen es nach gaza
zu gehen so schlimm ist interne teilung
in palästina geworden aber an diesem
punkt habe sich viele von euch sicher
okay das mit der spaltung ist klar aber
welches politische system hat die
westbank wie steht es um die wirtschaft
dort und was um alles in der welt geht
in gaza vor sich nun lasst uns diese
frage schnell beantwortet
also aufgepasst
[Musik]
das alles tina jenseits der schlagzeilen
das ist eines klar stellen die als
chinesische politik befindet sich in
kauf sie ist ein durchschlagen der
misserfolg so sehr dass impress tina
seit 2006 keine parlamentswahlen der
stadt gefunden haben und das ist schon
eine ziemlich lange zeit mehr als 15
jahre in denen die bürger ihre politiker
nicht wählen dürften
und das obwohl das britische modell
angeblich freie wahl erfordert dieser
desaströse zustand ist vor allem auf den
innerpalästinensischen konflikt
zurückzuführen zwischen den beiden
großen fraktionen vorab welche die preis
zwischen autonomiebehörde reagiert und
die hamas die den gazastreifen
kontrolliert ein konflikt der im jahr
2007 seinen höhepunkt erreichte
[Musik]
im jahr 2006 verlor die verdacht
liberalen in palästina knapp gegen die
hamas die 74 der 132 sitze
impressionistischen legislativrat
gewinnen kommt doch anstatt die macht
geregelt zu übergeben geräten die
parteien heftige auseinandersetzungen
denn die gemäßigte vertrag wusste dass
die hammers in ganz palästina ein
totalitäres regime errichten würde in
dem dann jeder demokratie erstickt würde
es wurde nach kompromissen gesucht um
die radikalen durch einbindung zum
mäßigen ähnlich den gescheiterten
versuchen hitler vor seiner
machtergreifung zu bändigen doch eine
kurzlebige dreimonatige
einheitsregierung ende der bewaffneten
konflikt im gazastreifen
dieser hielt von 2007 bis mindestens
2011 an
das ergebnis der gaza-streifen viel an
die hamas und das westjordanland an die
verdacht und genau in dieser situation
befinden wir uns heute erinnert ihr euch
noch daran als ich geh schröder nach der
verlorenen wahl 2005 machohaft weigerte
in einer fernsehrunde anzuerkennen dass
als kanzler nun die macht am angela
merkel wird abtreten müssen und jetzt
werde euch vor putin hätte ihnen damals
nicht von der straße geholt hätte
schröder dann das spiel weiter betrieben
und auch einen bürgerkrieg losgetreten
um zum beispiel in westdeutschland alte
regierung zu können während merkel nur
im osten an die macht gekommen wäre eine
ganz verrückte vorstellung aber in
palästina ist nur was realität
um aus diesem schlamassel herauszukommen
müssten die palästinenser natürlich
wieder wählen gehen aber die staaten
differenzen zwischen den
palästinensischen fraktionen haben es
immer wieder unmöglich gemacht
parlamentswahlen abzuhalten die letzten
waren für mai 2021 angesetzt wurden aber
aufgrund des angriffs der hamas auf
israel der zwischen april und mai
stattfand erneut verschoben tja was für
ein zufall aber auch dieser krieg den
die haben was los trat passt zu ihr sagt
reiser preis ausgezeichnet in den kram
und weiter ungestört in gaza reagieren
zu können
übrigens wurden auch die
palästinensischen präsidentschaftswahlen
die für den 31 juli 2021 geplant waren
auf unbestimmte zeit verschoben
[Musik]
so dieser stelle sollten der abakus
erklären wie das politische system
palästinas eigentlich funktioniert
beziehungsweise theoretisch
funktionieren sollte nun im grunde
handelt es sich um eine halb
präsidialrepublik was bedeutet dass die
macht zwischen einem legislativen organ
geben alles schöne legislativrat und
einem extensiven oder gar bestehend aus
dem präsidenten und dem premierminister
geteilt wird mahmud abbas ist seit nicht
weniger als 16 jahren der präsident sein
amt sollte eigentlich alle vier jahre im
rahmen von präsidentschaftswahl neu
bestimmt werden
tja wenn in palästina seit 2006
überhaupt nur eine gesellschafts wahl
stattgefunden hätte dann gibt es noch
den premierminister
der vom präsidenten gewählt und vom
parlament bestätigt wird und die
regierung bildet während der präsident
das staatsoberhaupt ist und somit auf
dem papier nicht immer besonders viel
macht bei gewöhnlichen
regierungsentscheidungen verfügt eine
kuriose jedoch ist dass die
palästinensische autonomiebehörde bzw
2013 geschaffen der halb anerkannte
staat palästina keine verfassung hat
[Musik]
daher wird lässt ihn an einem
grundgesetz regiert das 2002 von jassir
arafat geschaffen wurde und auch in gaza
die jahre aber nicht de facto angewendet
wird dieses grundgesetz liegt unter
anderem das islamische recht oder die
scharia als leitprinzip des rechts in
palästina fest oder die zugehörigkeit
des palästinensischen staates zur
gesamten arabischen welt
er stellt auch fest dass seiner
hauptstadt jerusalem ist eine stadt
deren ostteil dpa kontrolliert während
der besten zu israel gehört beide
staaten beanspruchen jerusalem als die
hauptstadt ihres jeweiligen starts in
der achse sind jedoch tel aviv in israel
und palästina die einflussreichsten
urbanen zentren des jeweiligen landes
und obwohl dieses grundgesetz den islam
als offizielle staatsreligion weil es
die nas festgelegt leben die
palästinenser im westjordanland im
allgemeinen unter einem säkularen regime
in dem zumindest begrenzte bürgerliche
freiheiten und bestimmte menschenrechte
garantiert sind im gegensatz dazu
unterhält die hamas im gazastreifen eine
regierung unter der führung von ismail
haniyeh diese praktiziert eine strenge
version der scharia die grundlegendsten
bürgerlichen freiheiten religiöse
pluralität und menschenrechte werden
dort nicht respektiert unter der hamas
regierung in gaza seien harte strafen
ihn seine grenzen international
anerkannten menschenrechte und der
tagesordnung bis hin zur hinrichtung von
frauen und homosexuellen aus sogenannten
ethischen und moralischen gründen was
von verschiedenen
menschenrechtsorganisationen immer
wieder angeprangert wurde aber von sehr
vielen westlichen journalisten meist
übersehen wird
auffälligerweise oft gerade von solchen
welche besonders laut schreien wenn
woanders auch nur ein marginaler
verdacht aufkommt frauen und es könnten
diskriminiert worden sein
aber so ist ihr wie sich der eigentlich
mit der wirtschaft auswirkt von leben
die menschen wirkt nun die wahrheit ist
dass palästina zumindest dass es dem
land nicht zu arm ist wie man vielleicht
auf den ersten blick vermuten mag
das liegt nicht zuletzt an den
stehtischen wachsenden wirtschaftlichen
beziehungen zu israel
jeden tag daran tausende und
abertausende von palästinensern israel
zur arbeit was es ihnen ermöglicht
höhere löhne zu beziehen und mehr geld
nach hause zu bringen es gibt auch viele
palästinensische einwanderer die in
israel leben und arbeiten in der tat
haben zwischen 15 und 40 prozent der
gesamten chinesischen arbeitskräfte in
den letzten 50 jahren irgendwann in
ihrem leben in israel gearbeitet
es sollte auch beachtet werden das
interesse an land die offizielle währung
der israelische schekel ist so dass es
keine probleme mit dem geldwechsel gibt
es bedeutet auch dass etwa 60 prozent
aller waren und produkte die von
palästina importiert und exportiert
werden nach israel gehen oder von dort
kommen
[Musik]
ja das stimmt israel ist ein abstand der
größte handelspartner palästina
ich frage mich ob die befürworter von
bds boykott desinvestition und
sanktionen gegen israel auch schon
bemerkt haben dass sie mit ihren
aufrufen auch der palästinensischen
wirtschaft und den menschen dort schaden
die dinge sind eben nicht ganz so
einfach wie manche denken nicht war aber
okay
trotz allem ist das palästinensische
bruttoinlandsprodukt pro kopf heute elf
mal niedriger als israels und während
die palästinenser den großteil der
verantwortung für diese situation tragen
es ist unbestreitbar dass die
hindernisse die endlosen check points
und die teilung des territoriums weil
sich die bewegungsfreiheit einschränkt
und ab hat auch damit zu tun haben wie
gesagt ein teufelskreis aus gewalt
sicherheitsmaßnahmen frustration und
dann wieder gewalt vergleicht man jedoch
die wirtschaft des westjordanlands mit
der anderer muslimischer länder sie die
zahlen plötzlich gar nicht mehr so
schlecht aus tatsächlich ist das cockpit
im westjordanland ähnlich hoch wie das
von ländern wie marokko und tunesien
welche in der islamischen welt zu den
eher fortschrittlichen ländern zählen
und sich nicht über irgendeine form von
besatzung beschweren können die dinge
sind also nicht so schlecht wie sie oft
dargestellt werden allerdings ist die
auch unter betonung des opferstatus ein
riesen business an sich internationale
hilfe ist eine sehr wichtige
einnahmequelle für nicht pressen
zwischen regierung welche diese mittel
dann für die bezahlung von öffentlichen
dienstleistungen und hilfen für
unternehmen verwendet leider aber auch
zur eigenen bereicherung und der
förderung von gewalt gegen israel
aber zurück zu etwas positiven dem
aufblühenden dienstleistungssektor der
immer mehr hochwertige kompetenzen die
hightech software umfasst die nähe zu
israel sollte dem nicht zu einem immer
größer werdenden transfer von fachwissen
[Musik]
viele palästinenser sind ist einfach
gesagt von ihren eigenen taten in elend
gehalten zu werden und versuchen sich
durch ernährung und bildung zu
emanzipieren eine positive entwicklung
die immer stärker zu werden scheint
allerdings gilt auch hier weit in gaza
finden wäre ein völlig anderes szenario
vor die zwei millionen einwohner
diktatur wird im wesentlichen durch
geldtransfers aus dem ausland am leben
gehalten aus befreundeten diktaturen wie
katar aber zu einem großen teil auch aus
der eu
das ist also die politische und
wirtschaftliche realität bei des tiers
wie ihr seht haben wir es mit zwei sehr
unterschiedlichen palästinas zu tun
beide mit vielen problemen aber eines
davon ist wesentlich vielversprechender
ist das andere und nach all dem bist du
jetzt an der reihe
glaubst du dass palästina ist
kurzfristig schaffen wird beide
fraktionen miteinander zu versöhnen und
das land zu einen und falls ja unter
welchen systemen was denkst du was die
zukunft für die situation bereit hält
teilt eure meinung bitte wir immer mit
uns oder auch einen anderen ich hoffe
dass euch dieses video gefallen wird als
er gibt uns bitte einen like teilt es
mit euren freunden und vergesst nicht
unseren kanal zu abonnieren macht gut
und bis bald
[Musik]